there's a lot that attracted me to this
role which is why I said yes immediately
and I think that there are things in
this part that I didn't even fully
explore I could have played this many
times over and done a little bit
differently each time and none of the of
the versions would be better than the
other I think when writing is really
really strong like that as it is in this
and and in almost all of Kenny's work
that it sort of creates that kind of
complexity that it's this you know that
like so that it can be done over and
over as plays are there are different
productions over and over and they they
are all good and all different and
that's how I felt about this that was
sort of overwhelming that the to think
about all the different ways that it
could be played that said there was
through the conversations that I had
with Kenny which were long and happened
often there was there were certain
guiding lights of direction that were we
just start to follow that sort of took
us down a path I guess by that I mean
that you know we decided that he's
holding on to all of it that this story
works best if the character is is not
letting out that very much that the only
way that he survives is by holding it's
he holding on to it and that includes
the guilt you know he feels responsible
for having for the death of his children
and so he's not gonna let himself off
the hook and letting himself you know
were to sit around and cry and feel bad
for yourself as a way of letting
yourself off the hook and when it's a
release so we decided that he would just
be very pent up and and so how does some
character like that get through the day
well they just don't relax very much but
they you know tend to just think about
the thing that's right in front of their
face and dealing with that his job what
required of him being very task-oriented
moving through the day that way never
wanting to sort of think about his past
or talk about his feelings when you
worked with someone like Kenny there's
no second guessing them I you know he
had great ideas no matter how hard I
worked the night before or to show up on
set thinking of the five different ways
I could play this or interpret the scene
and and you know got myself as sort of
authentically emotionally involved as I
could be Kenny still had five better
ideas and I did so he was he's you know
you just gotta play for the coach
because otherwise you're sort of playing
for yourself so I that's usually my
approach on any movie but in the case of
working with someone who wrote such a
beautiful script and it's directed to
other amazing movies you know I really
just locked out any other any other
noise and just tried to focus on what
Kenny wanted the best experience well by
working with good people I know that's
not a good answer I guess you get the
best out of it by being open to
receiving what the other person is doing
there are no no good actors really
they're just sort of what the other
person is doing and if you're able to
listen to them and respond and and also
stick to the the path you know it's a
balance between sort of staying to the
charted course there but also just sort
of you know reacting to the thing that
is unpredictable that's happening in
front of you oh maybe my kids yes
meaning that's well sometimes they'll
just tell me oh if I can't decide what
job to do I'll ask them and talk and
they always have very good practical
advice you know I think that my ex-wife
gave me
every good acting idea I ever had so she
had a big influence on me and my you
know also sort of like you become much
more sensitive person and you care about
different things when you become a
parent I think mostly and so you sort of
I don't I stop liking doing like really
violent movies and like playing those
kinds of parts or you know if there are
part of movies that I think weren't
handled responsibly you know in some way
I was more sensitive to that and thought
about the things that I was jobs that I
was a part of in terms of what sort of
message or idea of my sub me that I was
leaving behind for them and so before I
had kids I really was just lied to this
thing if I felt like it you know I made
my choices much more carelessly and
casually and now I think about the jobs
I take in different ways
[Music]